there's like those people that you're
like oh they have an amazing Instagram
because it's just like a lot of people's
dream lives GG gorgeous a Kardashian
Kylie Jenner
I love Kylie the Kardashians hosts a
photo and their private jets I feel like
I should be on there I mean what is it
inspirational about a private jet yeah
[Music]
the whole lifestyle associated with
private jets is very exclusive and
unattainable so as he'd reached out to
jet Sweden we coordinated this whole
shoot today
[Music]
I really like the idea of tricking my
friends oh I'm definitely gonna be
pretending like this is regular I went
shopping this morning
I bought the jacket and I bought the
dress this morning
I really wanted to kind of embody what I
thought a jetsedder would look like and
I feel like I did that it's more than
just like this pictures cute we should
post it there's a science of course we
have to bring our snapchat spectacles
enjoying the private life dude I'm
staffing everything I snapchat every
second of my life how you probably love
this stuff I didn't know what to bring
so I just bought over everything of that
[ __ ] a horse
like a Viking one this is Sid Sidney has
an Instagram account I am a middle
school science teacher and I started an
Instagram account primarily so my
students know that I'm with it like
expensive I think I look like I'm either
with you because they want your money or
I owe you money
perception is reality on Instagram you
want to stay true to yourself but you
also want to look super dope I'm not
gonna post my cousin's weddings on
Instagram something like this where I'm
taking photos on a private jet
absolutely they're Instagram famous now
I was lowkey channeling my inner Kendall
I can't wait to see the comments on
Instagram
do you really experience something if
it's not on snapchat or Instagram
nowadays I think Instagram is really
important because people can always find
you no matter what social media is like
making a paper airplane out of your
resume and throwing it out the window as
a recording artist we definitely have to
look like we have more money than we
actually have kind of a necessary evil I
guess the gram is only a highlight reel
of your life I felt like people probably
wouldn't be surprised if you said that
you owned this jet you know I've always
kind of been preparing for this
lifestyle and it was good to know that
like I was right
you look like Kendall Jenner that's fun
now Kendall Jenner she's coming for you
[Music]
[Music]